على مدار الثلاثين
يومًا الماضية ، نفذت الولايات المتحدة حوالي ست أو سبع
غارات جوية ضد طالبان في
أفغانستان
دعمًا للجيش الأفغاني ،
حيث تمضي الولايات المتحدة قدمًا نحو
الموعد الحادي والثلاثين من أغسطس
للانسحاب الكامل للقوات الأمريكية من العراق.
دولة في
آخر مرة نفذت فيها الولايات المتحدة
ضربتين في محافظة قندهار
ضد طالبان
ضد معدات تم الاستيلاء عليها وهي
عتاد تم تسليمه
للجيش الأفغاني كجزء من
الانسحاب
الذي استولت عليه حركة طالبان بعد
ذلك.  اجتاحت جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
ونُفذت العديد من هذه الضربات الأخيرة بطائرات بدون طيار
، واستهدفت ثلاث من الضربات الأربع الأخيرة
هذا النوع من
المعدات التي تم الاستيلاء عليها وفقًا لمسؤول دفاعي
مطلع على هذه الضربات ، رئيس
هيئة الأركان المشتركة
مارك ميلي.  قال إن
طالبان استحوذت على 212 أو 213
من أصل 419 منطقة في البلاد ، أي ما
يقرب من
نصف المديريات في  كل أفغانستان
لم يأخذوا حتى الآن أيًا من عواصم المقاطعات الـ 34 ،
لكنهم حاصروا حوالي نصفها
بشكل ميلي ، فيما يبدو أنه
محاولة لعزل المراكز السكانية ،
أصبح الآن سؤالاً عما سيحدث في
الأيام والأسابيع المقبلة.
الولايات المتحدة تقترب من الانتهاء من
انسحابها وسيكون هذا
سؤالًا رئيسيًا هنا
، احتفظ القادة في أفغانستان
وحولها والقيادة المركزية الأمريكية
بسلطة تنفيذ هذه الأنواع من
الضربات ،
ما يحدث بعد 31 أغسطس على الرغم من أنه
لا يعتمد فقط على الوضع داخل
أفغانستان
لكن حالة محادثات السلام المتوقفة
بين طالبان والحكومة الأفغانية
تتحرك إلى الأمام أورين ليبرمان CNN
في البنتاغون.